good morning john so as you are well
aware i've been spending a lot of time
on tick tock and this is because i
am addicted to tick tock i'd like to be
able to say that it's because i am a
professional
media analyst who needs to be able to
participate in trends in order to
understand them so that he can continue
to do his work and that's actually not
untrue this is part of what i do for a
living i think it's some of the best
parts of my novels and also with our
work complexly with scishow and crash
course we do need to understand
how people are getting information into
their brain so that we can get
information into their brains but like
facebook is also a pretty big player in
the media economy and i spend like 15
minutes there a month if you follow me
on facebook by the way and you're like
no you don't hank you're there all the
time
no that's just my tweets that get
reposted to facebook
so yeah i spend time on tick tock
because i like it and it's addictive but
also i'm aware
that like there are problems with the
platform like is it more of a security
concern
than facebook or twitter or instagram
considering that twitter just like a
month ago
had a hack that basically exposed all of
the direct messages of
all of its users to hackers i'm like it
doesn't actually get much worse than
that
and then obviously it's a platform that
is in turmoil the ceo just quit
microsoft and walmart are teaming up to
try and acquire the us
operations of tick tock because
otherwise the president might
ban it it's just messy it's a messy
place and all of this is you know it's a
little bit
above my pay grade like i'm happy to
analyze it and mouth off about it but
like i don't know how to run tick tock
what isn't above my pay grade though is
being a creator like that's a thing i
know lots about
like like a lot like more than anything
else and the fascinating thing about
tick tockers is that
almost all of them would kind of like to
be youtubers or
instagrammers if that's what that's
called and that's not a surprise to me
there's really good reasons to want that
and it reminds me
of back when we were first making stuff
on youtube and all youtubers wanted to
be in
tv or movies i mean yeah youtubers doing
like extremely well still going out for
auditions to be like
in bit parts and movies or in tv
commercials so this is a thing that i
learned about dreams we can really only
dream the things we've seen before
we want to go down the paths our idols
walked down but the thing that we forget
is that they didn't walk down paths
because those paths weren't there yet
they created them so when i look at
these young people who are extremely
talented and working very hard
what i think is two things first you
have no idea what you're in for and you
can never know and you wouldn't listen
to me if i tried to tell you and i'd
probably be wrong
if you did but second you are in the
perfect place
you are where you are supposed to be is
it tumultuous and fragile and do you
have no idea what tomorrow will bring
yeah yeah yeah and that's too bad but
it's also
the reason this exists right now it's
the reason it can be so
weird and vibrant and inspiring and
constantly surprising and that doesn't
mean you shouldn't be thinking about
potentially other paths that don't look
like tick tock but
probably you shouldn't be looking at the
paths that are really well trod and
full of people who have lots of power
already things are really tumultuous and
the clear paths are really full but this
situation might mean that there actually
are a lot of paths out there
that would be really useful and valuable
but haven't been blazed yet and that
sentence wasn't just about tick-tock
it was about 2020. every day i get to
wake up and mostly i get to walk some
fairly well-trod paths and that's nice i
like the comfort of that
i like having a direction that i know i
should go in so that i can go in it i'm
really grateful at this point in my life
to have that stability but also i found
that i need to at least sometimes
go off in directions that aren't clear
and that i don't know even where that
path is going or through an area where
there just
is no path i find that i've gotten
better at that i also find that that's
where i learn the most
and often where i feel like i can add
the most value especially when i look
behind myself and i see the path
it's there now and there are lots of
people who are finding it a nice one to
walk down
john i'll see you on tuesday